das ist ein neuer tankshop den wir heute
früher Leben in Deutschland ja wir
wussten ja dass der Tankrabatt seit
heute Mitternacht eben nicht mehr gilt
aber die Spritpreise die sind
tatsächlich sofort direkt nach
Mitternacht wieder durch die Decke
gegangen die meisten Tankstellen haben
gegen 1 Uhr in der Nacht um 20 teilweise
30 oder sogar 40 Cent pro Liter erhöht
der Tankrabatt der ist seit wenigen
Stunden weg und schon jetzt gibt's einen
neuen Tank Schock in Deutschland das
hier rechts ist der ganz aktuelle Blick
auf die Tankstellen gerade eben gefilmt
dort Havelland Hamburg quer durch
Deutschland einmal durch und im Schnitt
liegen wir jetzt bei über 2,20 für den
Liter Diesel und bei etwas über 2,10 €
für den Liter Benzin schlau also wer am
Abend noch fix einmal den Tank voll
gemacht hat einziger Nachteil daran an
vielen Tankstellen stand man da sehr
sehr lange an lange Schlangen in den
letzten Stunden des tankrabatts und
jetzt schalten wir zur Icon
Geschäftsführer der Tast Stellen an
diesem Tag an dem wir einen neuen
tankschock erleben ich glaube das kann
man so sagen Herr mönicke
naja in dem Sinne war es ja kein Schock
sie haben es schon gesagt die Steuer
Reduzierung wurde wieder zurückgenommen
und auf der Basis werden wir heute halt
auch unsere Tanks wieder auffüllen
müssen und entsprechend hat der Markt
doch reagiert ja viele haben damit
gerechnet dass es teurer wird aber das
sofort alles quasi wieder drauf
geschlagen wird also an vielen
Tankstellen ja heute früh sogar 40 Cent
wieder rauf das ist schon ein Schock
war ja inklusive und die noch drauf
kommt 17 Cent bei Diesel und 35 Cent bei
Benzin und alle Marken haben tatsächlich
pünktlich um Mitternacht und
letztendlich wir als freie Tankstellen
dann auch entsprechend erfolgreich
reagiert sagen wir konnten jetzt keine
großen Reserven mit in den in den
heutigen Tag nehmen denn die letzten
drei Tage speziell gestern war die
Nachfrage natürlich so immens hoch das
natürlich unsere Reserven auch erschöpft
sind und quasi heute Nacht um 4 Uhr
schon begonnen haben die Stationen
wieder aufzufüllen und zwar mit dem auch
für uns mit dem äh wieder erhöhtenersatz
sie sagen gerade Umsätze wahnsinnig
gesteigert noch mal im letzten Tag des
tankrabbads wie groß war da der Andrang
in den letzten Minuten den letzten
Stunden
das war schon Wahnsinn
Geschichte glaube ich noch nie erlebt
das ging schon eigentlich am Montag los
mit dem deutlich erhöhten Umsatz am
Dienstag lagen wir fast auf dem
doppelten Niveau von einem normalen Tag
und gestern hat dann noch mal alles
bekannte gesprengt wir waren also weit
über den doppelten Umsatz bis hin zu dem
fast dreifach machen und zwar gar nicht
bekannt dass wir dass wir diese
Kapazitäten in einem Tag überhaupt
schaffen können an die Kunden zu
vergeben aber irgendwann wie gesagt sind
auch unsere Lagerkapazitäten vor Ort
beschränkt und erschöpft wir haben
normalerweise so für maximal drei bis
vier Tage Reserve wir hatten keine
Chance mehr die auch nur unser zupfen
also unsere Tanks sind auch fast leer
getankt worden gestern wir haben ja im
Frühjahr im Sommer viel Wut an den
Tankstellen erlebt weil die Preise eben
so durch die Decke gegangen sind dann
hat der Tankrabatt diese Wut so ein
bisschen beruhigt weil man dann ja
tatsächlich über den Sommer irgendwann
gemerkt hat okay also es kostet immer
noch viel Geld zu Tank aber die Preise
sind doch merklich runtergegangen
zumindest in den meisten Wochen rechnen
Sie jetzt mit neuer Wut
ja die Kunden sind natürlich verärgert
und das kann ich auch verstehen aber man
sieht ja in dem Sinne was der Tankrabatt
jetzt im Nachgang auch gebracht wird wir
haben bei der Senkung erlebt dass es
dann als die erhöhte Nachfrage kam auch
in den steigenden hohlmarkt wieder ein
Stück nach oben gegangen ist nach erster
Reduktion in den ersten Tagen ich rechne
und hoffe jetzt auch damit dass das hier
vielleicht jetzt durch die geringe
Nachfrage die die Kunden tanken sind ja
auch für den nächsten Tage gut gefüllt
wenn der mineralmarkt der hohe Markt
nicht nach oben geht vielleicht eine
leichte Beruhigung hier auch wieder
sehen und vielleicht ein paar
wir werden dieses hohe Niveau gewinnen
müssen das sagte Eike mönickey
Geschäftsführer der Taste anstellen hier
heute früh bei Bild live an einem Tag an
dem wir sofort nach Ende des tankrabatts
erleben wie die Preise wieder durch die
Decke geht und wir sprechen jetzt hier
bei Bild live mit Herbert Rabel ja der
selbsttankstellen Pächter ist er
vertritt die Interessen der Tankstellen
in Deutschland ich grüße Sie herzlich
hierbei Bild live wir haben gestern
zuletzt gesprochen sie haben das ja
schon erwartet dass das heute ein
richtig guter Tag für uns alle wird für
uns alle die wir tanken wollen für alle
Autofahrer in Deutschland ich finde es
ist ein richtiger Schock den wir haben
gestern gerätselt wie ist die Reaktion
nach Mitternacht und das ging
tatsächlich sofort richtig rauf 30 40
Cent
ja
ist das schon eine Frage ja das ist eine
Frage ich erlebe das als Schock wie
erleben sie das
Pächter und ich kann Ihnen nur sagen
dass meine schlimmsten Befürchtungen
wahr geworden sind aber eigentlich bin
ich froh über diese Entwicklung weil es
zeigt was für optikkapitalisten in den
Konzernzentralen sitzen und es wäre
schön wenn sich die Politik mal
grundsätzlich jetzt angesichts dieses
tankshops haben sie ja sehr richtig
gesagt dass der sich mal anguckt wie mit
den Pächtern der Tankstellen umgegangen
wird und wie sich die Mineralölkonzerne
verhalten weil die haben alle alle haben
sie Sprit unter der Erde unter den
Tankstellen in den großen Tanks den sie
alle billig eingekauft haben und jetzt
verkaufen sie den mit dem Tankrabatt
obwohl sie ihn ohne Tankrabatt
eingekauft haben und das ist einfach
eine Sauerei auf dem Rücken der
Verbraucher und da sieht man wie die
agieren und deshalb wäre es gut wenn man
sich diese Konzernstrukturen und das
System Tankstelle mal gründlich anschaut
das heißt das ist ganz klar wer das
heute früh an den Tankstellen verursacht
das ist jetzt nicht Tankrabatt gemacht
sondern der Tankrabatt ist sozusagen der
Vorwand um richtig abzukassieren
das ist ganz genau richtig formuliert
der Tankrabatt ist der Vorwand um
richtig abzukassieren wir haben die
Situation dass alle Tankstellen haben
mit Tankrabatt den Sprit günstig
eingekauft diesen günstigen Sprit den
verkaufen sie heute für 35 Cent mehr und
bei Diesel für 17 Cent mehr oder sie
probieren es zumindest die einen machen
35 Cent die anderen machen 30 Cent dann
kriegen die anderen kleineren mit was
machen die großen dann ziehen die nach
und erhöhen ihrerseits die Preise um 10
15 20 Cent wir haben eine Preisspirale
nach oben angetrieben von den großen
Konzernen obwohl der Sprit eigentlich
viel billiger verkauft werden müsste und
sie kriegen die Wut ab an den
Tankstellen bei ihnen landen ja jetzt
sie wird einen Autofahrer heute wieder
klar bei uns landen die wütenden
Autofahrer als wären wir Schuld dabei
können wir gar nichts dafür unsere Leute
gucken aus dem Fenster reiben sich die
Augen und stellen fest Obst bei uns ist
der Preis ja um 35 Cent hochgegangen das
ist ja die Situation der kleine Pächter
der kann der weit der beeinflusst den
Preis überhaupt nicht die
Konzernzentralen drücken auf den Knopf
und erhöhen den Preis ohne dass
irgendeine an der Tankstelle davon was
mitkriegt und genauso behandeln Sie uns
ja auch von oben nach unten und das ist
das System Tankstelle und dieses System
Tankstelle wird heute auf einer Weise
sichtbar wie ich das gar nicht für
möglich gehalten habe
danke für das Gespräch hierbei Bild live
Herbert Rabel der die Tankstellen in
Deutschland die Interessen der
Tankstellen verträgt und wenn Sie heute
schon an der Tankstelle waren dann haben
sie dort einen richtigen tankschock
erlebt denn es ist in ganz Deutschland
so wir wussten ja der Tankrabatt seit
heute seit Mitternacht der gilt er nicht
mehr aber das ist so schnell geht dass
die Preise tatsächlich sofort direkt
nach Mitternacht wieder durch die Decke
gehen ja das hätte keiner wohl gedacht
die meisten Tankstellen haben so gegen 1
Uhr in der Nacht teilweise 20 30 oder
sogar 40 Cent pro Liter erhöht wirklich
die Uhr danach stellen wir sehen noch
mal die Bilder kurz nach Mitternacht
also das am unsere Kollegen heute früh
gefilmt Hamburg Havelland einmal quer
durch die Republik durch und dann ging
es wirklich eigentlich ja spätestens um
1 Uhr in der Nacht zack rauf und das
nicht langsam sondern sofort kamen 20 30
Cent oben drauf beim Diesel sind immer
so im Bundesschnitt im Moment bei 2,20 €
und beim Liter Benzin bei 2, in etwa und
das wird die nächsten Tage weiter
hochgehen sagen die Experten ja wir
haben gehofft dass sie das haben wir ihn
gestern auch gesagt gestern noch zur
Tankstelle gefahren sind und das haben
einige auch und deswegen kam es zu lange
langen langen Schlangen da hieß es
wirklich Geduld haben bisschen warten
bisschen das Handy in die Hand nehmen
lesen Motor abstellen das sind
vielleicht die Möglichkeiten die man hat
aber wenn man sich im ganzen Land
umschaut wir haben uns für Sie mal
umgeschaut dann scheint es so die letzte
Chance gewesen zu sein gestern im
Havelland hohe Preise in Hamburg hohe
Preise wir sind überall rumgereist und
es gibt derzeit muss man sagen
deutschlandweit eigentlich keinen Ort an
dem sie noch so billig tanken wie mit
dem Tankrabatt darüber sprechen wir
jetzt mit Michael Haberland vom Verband
mobil in Deutschland Grüße herzlicher
Haberland das ist so haben wir es
genannt tatsächlich ja wir wussten dass
der Tankrabatt ausläuft aber das sofort
direkt nach Mitternacht da so stark an
der Preis Schraube gedreht wird das ist
schon ein Hammer heute für alle
Autofahrer in Deutschland
ja natürlich
das sind zwar nur noch einige Liter
wahrscheinlich in den großen Tanks
vorhanden der am meisten großen
Tankstellen aber die werden sich alle im
Laufe des Tages Lehren und dann kommen
wir zu den alten Preisen wieder zurück
und wir waren ja schon mal bei fast drei
Euro für den Liter Diesel bei einigen
Tankstellen und in München sind wir
gerade momentan bei 2,20 € ungefähr für
den Liter Diesel auch das schon ein
unglaublicher Preis und das dürfte im
Laufe des Tages noch mehr werden und die
2,50 € sind dann in relativ groß der
Nähe leider muss man sagen für die
vielen Autofahrer und Pendler denn man
tankt ja nicht zum Vergnügen sondern
einfach weil man muss wenn man
berufsbedingt einfach muss und einfach
braucht ganz genau viele Pendler die
haben überhaupt gar keine andere Wahl
Menschen die auf dem Land wohnen die
haben auch oft keine gute Anbindung
jetzt um in die Arbeit zu kommen was
glauben Sie wohin wird das noch führen
wie weit kann das gehen und haben Sie
irgendwelche Tipps für Autofahrern sie
irgendwo und sei es im hintersten war ja
eine Tankstelle entdeckt wo man jetzt
anfangen kann
zusätzlich heißt ja immer unterwöchig
tanken und am Abend tanken auf keinen
Fall an einem Montagmorgen
beispielsweise oder auch Dienstagmorgen
sondern generell immer am Abend tanken
dann gibt es natürlich eine Reihe von
guter Tank Apps wo man immer wieder
nachsehen kann was ist denn die
günstigste Tankstelle fahre ich lieber
doch nicht zur fahre ich lieber doch zu
einer freien Tankstelle beispielsweise
tank-apps wie clever tanken oder tankfix
da immer gut und gerne natürlich
nachsehen und das ein oder andere
Sparpotenzial findet man dann ja doch um
da ein wenig Sprit zu sparen aber den
meisten Leuten ist es eben verwehrt
einfach wirklich Sprit zu sparen weil
sie es eben berufsbedingt brauchen das
Auto ist Verkehrsmittel Nummer eins in
Deutschland wird auch bleiben und andere
Länder machen sie ja ganz gut vor
Italien beispielsweise oder Frankreich
die haben den
Tankrabatt einfach verlängert jetzt mal
bis Ende Oktober und wir fordern von
mobilen Deutschland auch von unserem
Automobilclub aus verlängert ihn einfach
mal bis 31.12 sprechen auch über die
Verlängerung des neuen euro-tickets
warum nicht den Tankrabatt auch einfach
verlängern sie haben es richtig gesagt
wir sprechen darüber frankreich hat es
einfach gemacht die haben ja nicht bloß
verlängert die haben heute noch mal
ordentlich drauf gepackt da war es
bisher Tankrabatt 17 Cent jetzt sind es
30 Cent Tank Rabatt weil eben ja alles
noch viel teurer geworden ist also ganz
viele Millionen Autofahrer in
Deutschland werden gar nicht verstehen
warum man jetzt für drei Monate über den
Sommer entlastet und jetzt seit brutal
sagt nur gut das waren halt drei Monate
ab jetzt wird's halt volle Granate
bezahlt
es war ja richtig und wichtig auch wenn
oft viel gespottet wurde über den
Tankrabatt dass er jetzt kam eben Juni
Juli August dann vorhanden war Christian
Lindner hat sich da einiges an Kritik
anhören müssen aber per se war es jetzt
richtig aber folglich muss es jetzt auch
sein dass Deutschland dieses Tool das
man ja implementiert hat jetzt einfach
verlängert kann ja nicht so schwer sein
wenn schon vorhanden ist einfach zu
verlängern und wenn es andere Länder
auch machen dann sollte da Deutschland
einfach fordern Folgen sonst haben wir
wieder die rote Laterne die hat man
nämlich vor Juni schon die rote Laterne
in Deutschland nämlich die teuersten
Spritpreise in ganz Europa wirklich mit
Abstand die teuersten Spritpreise in
ganz Europa andere Länder können Sie
auch besser bei uns verdient der Staat
so viel Geld mit dem Sprit da sollte er
dann die Bürger dann einfach entlasten
und jetzt kommen so viele andere Sorgen
und Nöte und höhere Preise auf die
Menschen so in diesem Land da könnte man
dieses Tool wirklich einfach mal schnell
verlängern auch wenn es was kostet das
ist so in der Not muss man
zusammenrücken da muss der Staat einfach
mit
[Musik]